on passe maintenant à notre invité du
salon
vicious re bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes né
à la fin des années 80 en ile de france
de parents ouvriers et vous avez
quelques frères et soeurs c'est tout ce
que vous acceptez de dire sur vos
origines n'est ce pas oui ça ne protège
de certaines personnes qui n'aiment pas
trop notre mouvement
alors à l'école vous étiez un élève ni
bon ni mauvais vous étiez dans la
moyenne votre vie commence vers l'âge de
7 ans quand un ami de vos parents vous
offre un vieil ordinateur et avec l'aide
de votre frère vous le démonter
entièrement pour l'astiquer pièce par
pièce comme ça vous dit pour moi c'était
un gros légaux tous les jours je me
disais que je pouvais aller plus loin de
lendemain et à partir de là j'ai
toujours eu les doigts sur un ordinateur
vous avez attrapé le virus quoi ça m'a
appris beaucoup de choses et du coup j
ai pris nous lors au fil des ans vous
vous réfugiez de plus en plus souvent
dans l'informatique qui sera pour vous
un objet à la fois d'apprentissage du
monde et de loisirs
tout à fait
l'informatique et surtout internet
permet d'avoir des informations fraîches
de manière rapide et surtout de plus en
plus crédible ce qui n'était pas le cas
au début d'internet
alors après le bac vous faites des
études d'aéronautique où vous vous
épanouissez encore aujourd'hui hélas en
naviguant sur le web vous commencez à
vous passionner pour l'actualité
internationale
et un jour au début de l'année 2008 vous
découvrez une vidéo où tom cruise fait
l'apologie de l'église de scientologie
on voit tom cruise qui se met quasiment
à bavay en disant qu'il a une mission
divine
de convertir toutes les personnes sur
terre et que les autres sont des
personnes qui ne devraient pas exister
car mais la scientologie fait interdire
la diffusion de la vidéo sur le net et
j'ai cette tentative de censure qui
donne naissance au mouvement anonymous
auquel vous appartenez aujourd'hui voilà
alors vous sur votre écran vous suivez
la bataille entre la scientologie et
anonymous c'est le premier grand combat
des anonymous c'est contre la
scientologie wing d'ailleurs c'est ça
reste encore aujourd'hui notre objectif
principal
alors fin 2008 vous parvenez à retrouver
la trace d'anonymous sur des forums
américains en fait c'est un site qui
s'appelle forte shan xi sur le cadre est
pas obligés de s'identifier
tout à fait et c'est comme ça que vous
avez l'occasion d'aborder les anonymous
oui alors grâce à ces à ce forum for the
sun j'ai réussi à récupérer donc
l'adresse du site internet why we
prothèse pour n'être le site
international des anonymous voilà alors
quand vous leur demander des précisions
sur ce qu'ils sont il vous répond nous
luttons contre les sectes les dictateurs
et les lois liberticides
tout à fait j'imagine qu'hadopi c'est
pas là c'est pas la cam de des anonymous
bah disons qu'il ya quand même des
choses qui
nous plaisent pas vraiment dans les
méthodes des anonymous faut le dire sont
toujours pacifique acp oui les sites
internet ne sont pas détruits ils sont
tout simplement bloqué donc san père ça
nous permet donc de faire une
manifestation de grande ampleur où que
l'on soit et beaucoup plus médiatisée
qu'une manifestation dans la rue voilà
alors là vous décidez de vous lancer
dans l'aventuré sous le nom de deux
virus man le vicieux et puis un jour
donc c'est le contact avec la cellule
parisienne des anonymous et vous
découvrez quelques 150 personnes qui
sont impliquées dans la sphère dans le
dans le réseau parisien et environ 150
personnes oui alors au printemps 2009
contient le procès de la scientologie à
paris vous en profitez pour prouver aux
autres anonymous que vous avez
emmagasiné des informations et vous
obtenez un rendez vous oui tout à fait
alors là vous entrer dans le concret
julian assange et son site wikileaks
viennent de publier leurs documents
secrets en représailles les principales
sociétés de paiement électronique décide
de lui couper les vivres c'est
mastercard par exemple qui décident de
bloquer les comptes et les anonymous
utilisent leurs armes qui s'appelle le
déni de service voilà ça c'est leur
grande force c'est le déni de service
dans l'histoire c'est très simple c'est
qu'il faut bloquer le site en fait en
multipliant le nombre de connexions
voilà un peu comme si vous tout le monde
appelle quelqu'un au téléphone en même
temps évidemment le type il peut plus
servir son téléphone vous allez tout sur
le site de mastercard par exemple en
même temps oui un ordinateur peut
assimiler des milliers des mini voire
même des millions de connexions à la
seconde ce qui fait qu étant donné que
les serveurs ne sont pas prévus pour
recevoir plusieurs milliards ou dizaines
de connexion à la seconde le serveur
n'est tout simplement plus capable de
répondre il se bloque donc vous
invalider les serveurs des sociétés que
vous attaquez à ce moment là voilà dans
les lignes sont saturés donc et
l'opération qui s'appelle payback dure
une semaine et anonymous en sort
victorieux tout à fait alors il faut
savoir que cette opération a servi à
plusieurs choses la première à faire
comprendre que pour nous la liberté de
la presse la liberté de tous les médias
est prioritaire les médias sont quand
même la clé la clé d'une bonne
démocratie qui fonctionne or la couper
les vivres à un site de média qui plus
est de manière illégale parce qu'il n'y
avait pas eu de jugement ça nous
semblait totalement incroyable alors
l'opération suivante c'est benali
évidemment anonymous lancent des
attaques pour saturer les serveurs du
gouvernement tunisien et les rendre
inopérants tout à fait alors les
tunisiens nous ont contactés en nous
demandant de l'aide et nous nous leur en
avons fourni tout simplement ouais donc
là vous faites pareil le déni service
dire que au même moment les ordinateurs
du gouvernement tunisien sont assaillis
d'une certaine façon de 2 millions de
dhs appel oui tout à fait alors d'autre
part quand ben ali tente de contrôler
facebook youtube et twitter vous envoyer
des sms aux blogueurs tunisiens pour
qu'ils puissent se connecter malgré la
censure et qu'ils puissent poster des
images en fait en gros avec donc
certaines autres personnes des numéros
sécurisées ont été établies pour que
dans les pays étrangers notamment en
tunisie mais aussi encore aujourd'hui
par exemple en libye ces personnes
puissent se connecter en tout anonymat
et en toute sécurité ouais pour pouvoir
nous expliquer ce qui se passait dans
leur pays et mieux s'organiser
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que la
révolution de jasmin donc en tunisie est
né à la fois d'une immolation par le feu
c'est quelque chose de très antique on
pourrait dire et d'un cybersabotage
cette phrase ironique mais oui c'est
bien ça c'est fou alors vous continuez
évidemment avec l'egypte de moubarak
alors en fait ce que nous avons fait
c'est qu'étant donné que les lignes
internet n'était plus fonctionnel
puisque les serveurs avaient été coupés
à la source c'est-à-dire au à la prison
étant donné que les lignes téléphoniques
fonctionnait toujours avec un bon vieux
modem comme on avait il ya dix quinze
ans en france et un numéro de téléphone
il était tout à fait possible avec
quelques difficultés quand même de nous
envoyer des documents et des
informations
alors l'autre arme des anonymous c'est
le black fax ce que vous envoyez des
centaines de milliers de pages noires
sur les numéros de fax du gouvernement
et ça les fait cramer tout simplement
parce que
les facs sont en grande partie à
technologie laser c'est à dire l'écart
tonnerre ouais lorsque le fax se
retrouve à sailly il imprime donc toutes
les pages noires donc déjà ce qui fait
consommer énormément d'encre et le fat
ce nerf a tout simplement surchauffée à
planter
alors évidemment votre problème dans la
vie c'est la sécurité c'est hier que les
anonymous sont surveillés comme le lait
sur le feu par toutes les polices du
monde et les perquisitions et des
arrestations
alors voilà vous êtes obligés de créer
des faux profils facebook des faux
compte twitter et quand vous téléphonez
c'est avec des puces récupérés sur des
téléphones que vous obtenez dans les
lancements publicitaires soit dans les
lancements publicitaire loi soit l'heure
de soirée à l'étranger certaines grandes
compagnies téléphoniques donne des
numéros de téléphone et étant donné
qu'il n'y a pas d'identification
possible on les utilisons les
exploitants maximum ouais c'est comme
dans la résistance il ya une méthode de
cloisonnement c'est à dire que vous ne
connaissez pas plus de 3 anonymous ça
nous permet de poison et le réseau si
l'une des personnes et arrêté d'avoir
quand même le réseau qui continue de
fonctionner comme si rien n'était qu'est
ce que vous risquez si vous faites
attraper par la police personnellement
je ne crains pas grand chose tout
simplement parce qu'il faudrait qu'elle
puisse prouver que j'ai participé à des
activités illicites chez les anonymous
ya pas de chef on n'a pas de chef ça
permet justement aussi de protéger le
réseau chacun donne son idée
essaye de faire réagir les autres et si
unis débat se détachent du lot est
intéressante et bien les gens décident
donc de mettre cette idée en pratique
alors chacun est libre d'entreprendre
les actions qu'il soit en fait oui du
moment qu'ils respectent les règles les
règles importantes qui cloisonnent et
qui structurent notre mouvement vous en
pensez-quoi avec j'aime pas trop le
masque mais les objectifs sur louable
mais la sociologie ben ali ou bavarder
un combat il va dans le bon sens mais
j'aimerais qu'il soit plus à visage
découvert il peut pas vous pouvez pas
beaucoup trop dangereux c'est beaucoup
trop dangereux pour nous ce qui est bien
c'est que c'est non violent ouais c'est
des jeunes c'est une mobilisation
citoyenne en fait parce qu en fait
internet ça peut être le pire comme le
meilleur ça pourrait être utilisée par
des régimes totalitaires vous faire big
brother mais comme en même temps c'est
un réseau ouvert effectivement avec un
petit peu de génie informatique
on peut faire triompher la démocratie
contre le totalitarisme
tout à fait il faut savoir que chez les
anonymous il n'y a pas que déjà on a
vraiment de tout âges de toutes
catégories socioprofessionnelles et
aussi on a des femmes on a pourquoi
pourquoi vous en auriez pas
dans les organisations
qu'ils défendent ou qui font des choses
on voit pas les femmes alors du coup on
dit qu'il n'y en a pas là c'est faux non
on a des fans d'un autre mouvement qui
sont très bien appliqué très bien
intégré nages sont masqués comme vous
certaines sont masqués comme moi une
très très grande partie d'autres
d'autres d'apaiser les hommes c'est pas
très sexy c'est sûr l'attak de bercy et
l'élysée c'est vous c'est pas vous non
non non on a autre chose à faire que de
regarder jouer et non à mon avis et
d'autres à mon avis ça doit être
sept ans
peut-être que c'est les chinois peut
être que c'est les ruses peut-être que
c'est d'autres personnes en france en
tout cas c'est pas nous l'aurait
revendiquée et les documents réfuté
rapidement et j'aurais libye alors
qu'est ce que vous faites la libye on
utilise exactement les mêmes méthodes
donc que dans les autres pays qui ont
décidé de se libérer de même donc avec
communication de ligne sécurisé et
crypté
récupération d'informations que ce soit
des vidéos des textes des photos et on
essaye aussi d'attaquer tous les
serveurs du gouvernement libyen de la
police et de l'armée libyenne pour
essayer de les organiser un maximum et
essayer de limiter peut-être le nombre
de morts
[Applaudissements]
je vais
je nie pas à thiais à internet mais
juste écouter les fans de manivelle de
ma jeunesse et c'est vrai que j'ai aussi
une certaine réserve facebook jamais
quand je vois l'utilisation qu'on peut
faire de ça je suis ébahi et la voilà
devenue anonyme on accepte tout le monde
il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas deux ans
d'argent
merci de votre témoignage en rdc
j'espère vous ferez pas serré à la
sortie du studio c'est tout ce que je
souhaite et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux